[Music]
mr mark cuban
launches an online pharmacy to provide
cheaper medicine to the masses final
[ __ ] lead what a [ __ ] cool guy
taking on big farmer this guy he uh
launched mark cuban's cost plus drug
company aka literally it's mcc pdc okay
launched its online pharmacy on
wednesday offering a hundred different
genetic drugs ranging from cancer
medication to mental health medicine and
the company's focus is to help shield
people from inflated drug prices is it
live now or is it like it's live now
it's live now wow it's live now so
ultimately he pretty much is acting as a
wholesaler and making and the whole kind
of motif of it is to be absolutely
transparent with costs so everything
that he's providing for people is at
manufacturers costs plus 15 percent
and then there's like a three dollar
pharmacist fee wow but what you what
ends up happening is that for example
the retail price for a drug like and i'm
going to butcher this because i'm not
pronouncing hyperpacman imatinib
imaginative i don't know which treats
leukemia
usually runs upwards of 9 500 per month
but according to a press release from
the new company the lowest price you
might pay with the common voucher is 120
per month right so his company is
bringing that to people at 47
what a [ __ ] guy bro imagine like this
this if this lasts which i hope it does
he's going to change the whole [ __ ]
world dude like this is life-changing
[ __ ] forever being a huge pharmaceutical
factory that's 22 000 square feet in
texas right now uh that's gonna be done
by the end of the year that's incredible
do you think there's gonna be big pharma
assassins and ninjas that are trying to
assassinate his ass dude yeah he's also
a billionaire too right so he's got his
own ninjas yeah counter ninjas [ __ ]
houston rocket ninjas
i mean
my dad was uh he had he got prescribed
cialis for blood pressure even though
it's like that's a dick medicine
and then he was like hey uh right like
um go to this like right to this address
and it was in canada and i was like what
the [ __ ] and he goes my doctor told me
if you get the name brand it'll be like
i don't know three g's or some [ __ ] like
that and then if you get it from and you
have to get it i don't know every
quarter or something like that and then
he was like but if you go through this
route they'll fulfill the order but ship
it to my house and it'll only be a
couple hundred bucks
you know i'm like what the [ __ ] it's
crazy the middle man that's the whole
point cutting out the middleman
wholesale the middleman is on average
minimum over 100 markup on genetic drugs
minimum
and and with many pharmaceutical
companies doing uh a one thousand
percent markup
capitalism one
thousand percent that's why we need
universal health care people will be
like no
i want to pay for it i'm like all right
it says that about 18 million people in
the us were unable to pay for at least
one prescription medication for their
household according to a september 2021
gallup poll and additionally some 10 of
americans have skipped doses of
medication in order to save money that's
insane you know what's crazy too is that
the government um blows a [ __ ] ton of
money on medicare right but then they
don't [ __ ] bargain for these prices
either so they just accept sometimes
they even pay more and full retail when
they're buying so much drugs in bulk and
it's like
hmm you know you guys have all this
money you could probably get a lower
price and wholesale price while you're
buying it for retail makes no sense to
me so they can pass it to us
yeah and mark it up baby everyone just
has these handshakes in the back when i
was working in supply in the military
like i could see the cost of everything
i remember just like like you know when
you're bored you just type it in
whatever and i would type in like
springfield armory um m16 and i'm like
800.
i mean that's how much it is at like
turner's or something i'm like if the
government is buying thousands or of
these
shouldn't it be like 300 yeah and i'm
like damn i started looking at
everything and i'm like holy [ __ ]
they're just buying all this [ __ ] at
retail
so they're just everyone's just like hey
buy a million of these off of you and
then you sell it to me at full price
okay okay see what they need is every
one of these deals
needs an asian person to negotiate two
and a half oh yeah one only one one does
he one if it's two it's too many cooks
in the kitchen
you just need so it doesn't matter what
asian country you just need a on asia
but if you had to pick one you had to
only pick one asian foreign i'm
obviously going to be partial to indians
okay all right that's your bias that's
that's fine you know i i know my people
i like it like everyone else knows their
people who gets the cheaper price indian
or chinese you're about to start world
war three
i think they're very they're they're
they're really good negotiations might
be the last episode of jk news
[Laughter]
indians are great when i when my first
job when i worked at uh basically what
is t-mobile now in cerritos mall you
know when you had to like shark phones
to people hey you got a phone bro yeah
and like not everyone had phones but the
indian customers i would get yeah they
made me rethink what i could and
couldn't do
he's like yo
he's like this dude is like how come no
coverage on this side and i was like oh
we don't have coverage over here there
for that and he's like why not and i was
like
yeah why not
[Laughter]
he was like i'll only get it if i get
coverage here that's what i'm saying
maybe we can get some towers up for you
man like
[Laughter]
he's like climbing the electrical pole
putting it up before his cost back then
no phone company had full coverage
anyway yeah it was you just got the
coverage based on what like you could
get singular if you only wanted this
singular
these indian dudes and cerritos were
dope imagine just like one single just
indian auntie negotiating for all of
them
machine
that's not going to work for me
you know bullets are okay
the gun needs to go down
you're like all right [ __ ] it we gotta
do it too
[Music]
it's like something that's beyond your
power but you feel like you can do it
you're like all right if we work
together me and you we'll make this
happen
dude you get a japanese negotiator in
there and it's like you'll be like all
right it's gonna be a hundred bucks a
gun and they'll be like no i give you
120 dollars
[ __ ] reverse you work so hard you
deserve more
[Laughter]
my buddy
he worked at toyota lexus um out in the
south bay hello japanese customers and
he goes man he's like
most asians are tough he goes koreans
will come in they're tough you know like
chinese they're tough japanese people i
could charge them over msrp no questions
asked they'll pay for it they just say
yes
i'm like so you're out there exploiting
your own people he's japanese too and
he's like yeah they're the easiest ones
to take
30-year freaking time because there's no
bargaining culture
in india no matter where you're at you
bargain right yeah anything they'll be
like hey we're selling you this bottle
of water it costs five dollars and i'll
be like ah
i'll give you one and they'll be like oh
no sir dude dude that's two no
i'm like all right i'm out right now
obviously they know i'm american yeah
and then when i walk away they're like
come back come here no sleek and i'm
like it's 50 cents now and i'm like 50
25
and then i'm like ah
30 and i'm alright deal
yeah so you got to do a 30 minute
conversation for a bottle of water
that's why you if you're going shopping
in india
you need to go with the intention of
like i actually need to buy something
like window shopping you'll be get
sucked into a black hole of just
negotiating and then you'll be like run
into somebody else around a brown hole
because they'll pull you in even if
you're not buying yeah they'll just be
like yeah come in come in right like the
whole nine yards like they do the whole
old school salesman pitch and they know
you're a tourist right
and so they'll first say nin dollars and
you'll be like absolutely [ __ ] not
because then i can buy the store
and so
we need a immigration program where we
have indian negotiators working for the
us government and if they depending on
how much money they save is how they'll
get their citizenship
wow so india has like this like they do
this all the time so we're going to see
the taj mahal okay my parents are from a
different city the taj mahal is in agra
my dad's from chennai which is south
india so he doesn't really speak hindi
so we're getting there and they have the
ticket price and it's like
indian citizens and like non-indian
citizens so obviously none of us are
gonna get by but my parents could easily
just you know speak in hindi and just be
like yeah we're citizens
my dad for the first time in his life it
was like a very thick indian accent the
dude speaks to him in hindi we speak a
language called
so he doesn't he can't really respond
instead of responding in tumble he looks
at me and my brother and he's like
yo what the [ __ ] is this joker talking
about like uh like just like straight
like a new yorker like new york bronx
like just straight up mafia i'm like dad
what the [ __ ] i was like for the first
time in like like the 30 years of my
life your accent disappeared and you
were like yo look at this [ __ ]
clown i'm like what the hell i was like
why did you just respond to him
we all got to charge the american
president
[Laughter]
the one time the one time i was like he
he's like i don't understand him i was
like he doesn't understand you so he
fumbled it he mean like we were arguing
over like probably like two american
dollars
at the end of the day but like straight
up my dad hasn't like it's like really
thick he could have said anything like
no and the [ __ ] balls on this guy huh
this [ __ ] jabroni yeah this
[ __ ] like what the [ __ ] is up
with this dude curtis
jesus christ dad i was like what the
[ __ ]
although it was very funny because me
and my brother were like there he is we
were like of course
[Music]
you